hola este es el vídeo de química
esencial número 56 y hablaremos de los
sistemas biológicos y los polímeros si
analizamos la sangre nos encontraremos
con mucha emodina y la hemoglobina se
produce en un ribosoma que se ve como
esto tenemos una serie de aminoácidos
que están unidos por enlaces covalentes
formando una cadena como ésta y en el
momento en el que sale la hemoglobina de
la ribosoma ocurren fuerzas inter
moleculares los puentes de hidrógeno
crean una hélice alfa y una lámina beta
y después se unen y las regiones
hidrofóbicas se mueven hacia adentro y
las hidrofílicas hacia afuera así
ocurren muchas fuerzas de dispersión que
van uniendo a las diferentes partes de
la molécula hasta que se forma esta
proteína un poli péptido que se encarga
de una función específica así que no
solamente los enlaces covalentes son
importantes sino también las
interacciones no covalentes
entonces en una molécula grande la
estructura es decir cómo está unida debe
estar relacionada con su función si la
estructura no es correcta entonces la
función tampoco lo será y bueno decíamos
que la estructura puede estar compuesta
por enlaces covalentes que mantienen a
la molécula unida pero también existen
interacciones inter moleculares como los
puentes de hidrógeno las fuerzas de
dispersión y todo esto trabaja en
conjunto para lograr una estructura
específica que pueda realizar una cierta
función por ejemplo una enzima tiene que
tener una forma perfecta para que el
sustrato encaje perfectamente y pueda
cumplir la función de romperlo por eso
cuando empezamos a crear polímeros de
este tipo es importante entender cómo
sus estructuras se relacionan con su
función y miren muchas de estas
moléculas son polímeros eso significa
que están hechas por muchos monómeros al
igual que esta palabra
está hecha de muchas letras
les enseñaré algunos ejemplos este
monómero es el tereftalato de etileno
cual será el polímero que obtendremos si
juntamos varias moléculas como esta
bueno obtendremos poliéster que se usa
en la ropa y si por ejemplo tenemos este
monómero glucosa si juntamos varias
moléculas obtenemos un polisacárido como
el almidón o si tomamos este aminoácido
y juntamos varios de estos monómeros
obtenemos esta proteína gigantesca pero
lo que mantiene a todo esto unido son
todas las fuerzas internos leku lares
entre las diferentes partes de la misma
molécula entonces si analizamos una
molécula como el adn en realidad estamos
viendo los enlaces covalentes entre
todos esos átomos que le dan la
estructura pero lo que no vemos son
todas las interacciones que no son
covalentes por ejemplo en todos esos
sitios existen puentes de hidrógeno que
mantienen a las dos hélices unidas
tenemos fuentes de hidrógeno en la parte
externa que le dan la estabilidad a la
doble hélice así que si no tenemos
enlaces covalentes e interacciones no
covalentes no tendremos una molécula que
funcione e igualmente si tenemos este
polipéptido con todos estos aminoácidos
los enlaces covalentes por sí solos no
nos dan esta estructura y recuerden que
la estructura de una proteína es muy
importante ok y finalmente veamos una
molécula biológica las enzimas que son
catalizadores hechos de proteínas y cómo
funciona una enzima bueno podemos ver
que tiene un lado activo en el que
encaja el sustrato entonces el sustrato
entra y ocurre una interacción entre la
enzima y el sustrato con lo que la
enzima aplica tensión y lo rompe y así
disminuye su energía de activación
entonces si no tenemos la estructura
correcta si no tenemos estas fuerzas
inter moleculares
entre la enzima y el sustrato la enzima
no funcionaría ahora si entendemos cómo
la estructura está relacionada con la
función podemos empezar a diseñar
polímeros que hagan cosas muy
interesantes como por ejemplo el teflón
la estructura del teflón que es un
polímero nos da su función un
recubrimiento en el sartén para que la
comida no se pegue y si analizamos el
kevlar
su estructura nos da una función de
rigidez que nos permite crear una
protección como un casco o un chaleco
protector y si analizamos el nylon
podemos ver que aquí hay muchas fuerzas
inter moleculares entre las hebras
adyacentes de nylon y eso nos da su
función
entonces aprendieron a identificar tanto
las interacciones covalentes como las no
covalentes ojalá que sí espero que les
sirva